-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with our friend
Natasha Lyonne, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You shot this show all over,
including Las Vegas, New Mexico.
How does someone like you --
-If you say so.
-A city person like yourself,
how did you feel
with the desert environment?
Did you enjoy working there?
-Um, so, you know, I...
[ Laughter ]
You guys don't know my life.
-You're reacting like this is
a gotcha question.
-First of all, I will say,
it's always surprising to me
to hear the locations.
I know I was there,
but it's like a memory.
But I -- Yeah, I don't love
heat, as a rule.
You know,
I don't mind dry desert heat.
I think I like the sort of --
the landscape, the expanse,
uh-huh,
but I don't love my hair.
It's a lot of hair, Seth.
It's like a sable coat.
And what comes with that,
you know --
You know I also --
I write, I direct,
I produce like gangbusters.
-Oh, yeah.
One of our foremost producers.
-Well, and -- I'm like
a young Bob Evans figure,
but we know this.
The point is, when acting,
you've got -- There's a lot of
touching involved,
which is -- I like touch,
but by choice.
-Yeah. I think
that's pretty much
where everybody
is landing these days.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-If we've learned
one thing recently.
And I'm like a cat that way.
But, you know, such is
the lot of the actres-s-s-,
which is how it's pronounced.
A lot of people say it wrong.
-Yeah, you do --
You put three S's on it.
-Yes. Yes.
And, so, there's a lot of
extra touch involved
in the heat, and, you know,
so I don't love --
My dream is to be
a winter actress,
only because then I could --
But I'm fine to be
a summer writer or director.
-Okay, so you'll sort of work --
You'll do sort of behind
the camera in the summer months
and then on-screen
for "Zhivago" and the like,
the great winter works.
-First of all, exactly, Seth.
Like, those hats and
Julie Christie --
that's a picture.
-That's what you want.
-That's a winter picture.
That's why you
leave the house for acting.
-Now, you --
Because "Russian Doll,"
which is a wonderful show,
you know, a show you created,
you shot that how close to
your actual apartment?
-Right. So, yeah, you know,
I run it,
so, you know, it shoots
two blocks from the house
and in the dead of winter,
in the middle of the night.
And I wear one outfit,
and it's a black overcoat.
So, something to think about.
-Now, you've got --
You did go to school thinking
you would do film stuff,
but you did not stay
through-out.
-Yes. That's how
that's pronounced.
-Through-out.
-Yes.
-Well, that's like how
a professor would say it.
"Natasha, your grades.
We're not sure you're
going to stay a-through-out."
-I see you have been to college.
So, yeah --
So, here's what happened.
So, I was like what? 15, 16?
And I said,
"Alright, school, I get it.
I'll try for one, for Tisch,
and then I'll go there.
I'll be a film and philosophy
double major,
if they accept me."
And I write this thing,
T.S. Eliot, whatever,
and I -- They send me
back some sort of a note.
"You're hired"
or whatever colleges say.
So I show up there.
-"You're hired."
When I got into college,
it was a post-it note that said,
"You're hired."
-So, I show up and I say,
"Great, I'm 16."
I think they were more 18 or so.
-Yeah.
Historically,
that's usually what they are.
-Then good for them.
And I -- Then they put me
in this class,
and it's Cinema Studies 101.
And, you know, it was like,
"We're going to watch
'Apocalypse Now.'"
And so I went right to
the dean of admissions
and I said, "Now, listen,
I have seen 'Apocalypse Now.'
You know, I've read
'Heart of Darkness.'
I've seen the documentary
'Hearts of Darkness.'
I loved it.
The horror,
the horror of my tuition"
is what I said.
And I said, "If you think
I'm going to pay
to hang out with
these teenagers and talk about
'Apocalypse Now,' -- If you
haven't seen 'Apocalypse Now'
by this age, why are you
in film school, honey?"
Like, so, my dream was,
I was going to read all this,
you know, philosophy.
I was going to write these
sort of, like,
Bergman, but comedies,
and direct them.
And, anyway, I tried to,
you know,
retroactively negotiate
my way into a scholarship.
They wouldn't give it to me.
-Yeah. It's tough.
Once you've already
written them a check,
they tend not to --
-I never did is the point.
-Oh, gotcha.
-I left.
And, instead, I --
There's a great education
available to you in this city
at the Film Forum,
and, also,
in the back of The Times,
there will be things like YMCAs,
where you can go
in the middle of the day
with just a few --
like, a scattered bunch of
very old people.
And on a little
foldout metal chair,
I would watch, like,
all the great noir films,
and I loved it.
-Yeah. Did you first see
"Gaslight" in a Y, likely?
-Yeah, probably. Yeah.
-Yeah.
And, now, this is --
You know, again, obviously,
just based on that story alone,
we know that the depth of the
interesting things that
have happened in your life.
You believed you grew up in
Herman Melville's house.
-This is also true.
-Which is an
incredible thing to grow up
in Herman Melville's home.
-Yes, or so I thought.
-How do you get that wrong,
I guess?
-Yeah, well, you should ask your
friends at "The New Yorker."
Surely, you've read it.
-The magazine?
-Yeah.
I mean, they do this thing
there, I guess,
called fact-checking?
-Yeah.
-I don't know.
Like, who is it for?
You know what I mean?
We get it.
You guys are smart or something.
I don't know. College.
So -- Yeah, so, I guess
they told me that,
"Yes, your childhood was a
sham," which I already knew.
-So, did you tell a reporter
that you lived in --
-The story I was told.
-Okay.
And then they
came back to you and said...
-And I was like, "Well, who else
is claiming Herman Melville?
And are all these people
running around being like,
'I lived in Moby-Dick's house'?
Like, calm down.
Give me one thing."
And, so, anyway, it turns out
I did not grow up
in Herman Melville's home,
if that's where this is leading.
-That was my gotcha question.
-If that's why you brought
me here, today, Seth, you win.
Again.
-You know what?
You walked in here on your
high horse, being like,
"I lived in Melville's house."
and now we all know the truth.
-Yeah.
-Did you really watch
a couple of animals, like,
meet their demise
in your home growing up?
-Uh...
-Rabbits?
-I did Seth, yeah.
-So, what happened?
-Yeah, well, you know,
it was a rocky road.
And I guess --
Well, my parents --
I want to say
they were eccentrics,
but they were just alcoholics.
-Okay.
-And --
-Were you worried
"The New Yorker"
was going to fact-check it?
-Yeah.
And then -- So, yeah, I guess
they overfed
the sheep and the rabbits.
And, you know,
I love animals, so --
-Do you have pets now?
-Of course. Rootbeer.
I give her many --
-Whoo!
-Wow. I like that it's
a Rootbeer Head.
But, I mean,
I give her a lot of snacks,
but I would never explode her.
Yes, no.
-That's how the sheep went?
A full explosion of --
-That's what I remember.
I don't know.
-But you remember a lot wrong.
-Yes.
Or too right. Too right.
You know?
-It was.
-Yeah.
-It was two rights make a wrong.
-Yeah, it's not as easy to get
a lobotomy as it used to be.
-Oh, my God.
Well, I will hope you
never get one
and I hope you keep coming back.
And, my goodness gracious,
it's such a fun show.
And it's always
such a delight to see you.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's no one like
Natasha Lyonne, everybody.
New episodes of "Poker Face"
stream Thursdays on Peacock.
We'll be right back with
Adam Pally.